Canada and the world still have many
questions questions that must be
answered earlier this morning I spoke
with President rouhani of Iran I told
him that Iran's admission that its own
Armed Forces unintentionally shot down
flight 752 is an important step towards
providing answers for families but I
noted that many more steps must be taken
a full and complete investigation must
be conducted we need full clarity on how
such a horrific tragedy could have
occurred families are seeking justice
and accountability and they deserve
closure I reiterated to President
rouhani that it is absolutely necessary
that Canada participate in this
investigation we expect the full
cooperation of Iranian authorities
currently three visas have been approved
for members of the standing Rapid
Deployment team we expect that the lead
members of this team will arrive in
Tehran around 4:00 p.m. today and
establish a presence on the ground to
support Canadian families additional
team members will follow we're working
with our partners who are facilitating
the process by which visas are granted
and currently the Iranians are
cooperating in granting visas elderman
Appel Victor please now honey eagle
ma-kun Dani also condemned the actions
does the Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau he's speaking from Ottawa and
he's giving an update on the plane that
was downed in Iran he traditionally does
speak in English as well as French both
languages so some of what we've just
heard him speaking in say in English is
that Canada is demanding full
responsibility and accountability for
that flights to me let's listen in once
again a berate to give closure to the
victims deescalate tensions in the
region and continue this dial
our focus remains accountability
transparency and justice for the
families and loved ones of the victims
as Minister shopping said yesterday our
government is taking additional steps to
provide more support to those grieving
I've asked the clerk of the Privy
Council to set up an emergency Task
Force which convened earlier today
additionally consular and immigration
officials have been dispatched across
the country so that they can be in
direct contact with the families of
Canadians affected by this tragedy
Minister manda Chino has set up an
emergency line to ensure that officials
from Immigration Canada are available to
help with any visa issues Romania
shopping in one name continued myself
we'll continue to be in contact with all
government agencies to make sure that
the families receive the support they
require I speak to all the leaders and
premier ministers and when Canada
Canadians see great difficulty they
stand in solidarity and we will be here
for our neighbors for our communities
and our citizens this compassion acts to
comfort those who are touched by this
tragedy but will not cease to ask a
demand answers we will be here I will be
here to watch that light will be shed on
these events as are my ministers last
night I spoke to Prime Minister Abe a of
Japan who is on his way to the Middle
East and I will soon be speaking again
with Ukrainian president szalinski and
Swedish Prime Minister xi minister
shopping has been in touch with his
counterparts from Iran Switzerland
Turkey
Sweden and Ukraine in part to discuss
progress on issuing visas for our teams
he will also reconvene a second call of
the International coordination and
response group for the families of
victims of PS 752 to coordinate our
response for the families together with
representatives from Ukraine Sweden
Afghanistan and the United Kingdom who
are also grieving the ministry got new
city government with new avec de Soto et
al says due to Georgie jisu I assure you
that all those discussions will be
ongoing I want to end by sharing with
you a bit of what I did yesterday I had
a chance to sit with some of the
families of the victims they are hurt
angry and grieving they want answers
they want justice what Iran has admitted
to is very serious shooting down a
civilian aircraft is horrific Iran must
take full responsibility
Canada will not rest until we get the
accountability justice and closure that
the families deserve I'll go into what
may I'll see that what do you know to us
Matt that remain upon bogus Joe we're
gonna start will now take Molly Tyson
and afternoon prime minister now that
Iran has admitted guilt are you can more
confident that families are gonna be
able to bring their loved ones home and
is there a timeline on that this the
admission of Iran of responsibility in
this horrific crash is a very important
first step and we have seen from Iran a
willingness to facilitate consular
access a support for the families but it
is too early to have a sense of
timelines in terms of when they will be
able to return with their family members
you said it's a chance to speak with
rouhani I mean should Iran compensate
Canadian families here that is certainly
something that is going to need to be
part of the mix ice
down with a number of families who are
absolutely devastated with the loss of
loved ones they are facing financial
challenges on top of the extraordinary
grief that they are feeling right now
and we need to make sure that those
families get the justice that they
deserve so Matt you going rather kind of
done and then we're gonna go to Mia wrap
some canadian press that's a good house
you kind of see up there and ute do you
have from president rouhani that this
there will be a full and independent
investigation how much trust you put in
the Iranian authorities answer I think
the fact that they've accepted
responsibility for the missile strike
which brought the plane down I think
that establishes already that they're
open to having an investigation to find
out exactly what happened we need to
make sure obviously that it's a credible
investigation with independent
international investigators involved but
once Iran took responsibility for what
happened there has been every indication
that they were open to a full and open
investigation obviously there have been
calls for a credible international
investigation from the very beginning
the fact that Iran has now taken
responsibility for the downing of that
aircraft means that it is likely that
they will be full participants and fully
allow a credible independent
international investigation with all
partners involved we still have work to
do to ensure that happens but the
question of responsibility I think takes
us a step forward towards truly having a
very credible and thorough investigation
continue so you don't forget
Oh Iran draws a direct connection
between this tragedy and the conflict
with the US do you make any such
connection
so the answer I think that in times of
conflict and tension that's precisely
when innocent lives are lost obviously
in this context in the Middle East these
days that contributed to this tragedy
but Iran did the right thing and took
responsibility for the downing of this
plane and for this tragedy and both to
Canada mr. prime minister the you said
that the tensions in the region sort of
contributed to this and you expect Iran
to take full responsibility but Iran is
still pointing some fingers at the
United States as are many others for
raising tensions in the first place do
you share those views and do you plan to
speak with the US president and discuss
it I've had a number of conversations
with the US president recently recently
and will continue to the reality is
there have been significant tensions in
that region for a long time and what we
are calling for now is a de-escalation
to ensure that there are no more tragic
accidents or loss of civilian life as
well as moving forward to the peace and
stability that is deserved by everyone
in the region our focus right now is
primarily on ensuring accountability
answers and closure for the victims and
that is what we are engaged with the
Ukrainian Air Lines executives are
questioning why Iran didn't warn them
about this that there were potential
missiles in the area that they didn't
close the airspace are you confident
that this was actually an accident this
is one of the issues that we certainly
need better answers to and that's why
this first step of ignition of
responsibility is an important one by
Iran but there are many other questions
like that one that will need clear
answers to in the coming days of leaks
okay so for school rhetoric either and
this can be actually Berk CDC but I
suppose that's Canada Canada I'd like to
know a lot of families have said that
they're angry and upset what's your
reaction Prime Minister are you also
upset yes I'm furious that
there are Canadian families that have
lost their parents their children their
spouses it's a huge tragedy for the
entire country not just for the Iranian
community the Iranian Canadian community
is a community that has contributed
greatly to Canada's prosperity they work
very hard they're very involved they've
believed in this country and the future
that they've built here for many of
those families that has all been struck
down out of the blue by a regime that
they had fled in the past that they
believed they had gotten away from this
is an accident or an incident that is
truly horrible and I am angry I'm
disappointed but I am firmly committed
to getting answers and compensation and
help and justice for the victims I am of
course outraged and furious that
families across this country are
grieving the loss of their loved ones
that the Iranian Canadian community is
suffering so greatly that all Canadians
are shocked and appalled with the
senseless loss of life
the Iranian Canadian community is one
that has contributed tremendously to
this country hardworking and proud
Canadians contributing every day to
building a better future for themselves
and their kids and too many families are
destroyed the many of these families
have fled around fled the regime tried
to build a better life for them
elsewhere and to have the regime that
they have left behind
accept responsibility for this is a
bitter pill indeed